good afternoon sir would love to the
idea about the dirt ain't it hey it is
sir it is how may we help okay so I am
having a question concerning basically
can I pause my deck for a car
why
yes because one I believe I can become
more when I like to consider myself a
hustler as I may be able to get a
part-time job delivering pizzas or bring
doordash that sort of thing and so
therefore I can increase my income no
you don't have a car
uh no sir currently I do not have a car
oh okay
yeah I would
I would I mean basic transportation is a
that's a that's a starting point
yes sir and you can increase your income
a lot of different ways if you have just
a basic car you're gonna you know pause
your that snowball and pile up some cash
and pay cash for a car right
uh yes sir and how much of a car and how
long is this going to take
um yeah so so currently I have about
um 14 14 and a half thousand uh liquid
and I have a 12 12. oh you aren't doing
that at the snowball
oh you know sir because uh my student
loan is my current is my only debt
currently yeah but you have fourteen
thousand dollars cash saved
uh yeah well I have fourteen thousand
dollars a spread across a money market
account savings account uh my uh my
emergency yeah well if you were doing
the debt snowball you would have already
cashed all that in and thrown it at the
debt so you're not really doing anything
yet
okay so you got fourteen thousand
dollars saved so how expensive a car are
you gonna buy
thinking of getting something that's
like and I said Dan not not so much
hoopty though so maybe about
seven to ten Grand maybe a little bit 12
12 Max 12 Grand Max well let's think
about the price how much are your
student loans because that's going to
weigh into how much you spend on a car
oh yeah so I have currently I have 12
483 of student loans
and what do you make a year now
uh what would I make a year now I'm I'm
working part-time but I'm soon to be
employed at Fidelity and I will be
making fifty fifty thousand dollars a
year accessibility
soon to be is when
uh soon to be in June of this year are
you graduating from school
yes sir I graduated uh last December so
when when were you hustling when was the
hustling part
uh you're working part-time since
December
oh no no I was so I was I was working a
full-time job with my church I was uh
interning at my church full time with no
pain
oh no no it was paid oh okay
yes all right so let's let's start again
all right the baby steps are you have
one thousand dollars in the account you
throw everything else at your debt
smallest to largest until you're debt
free then you build an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses in baby
step three okay so that's the process
you would be using from this point
forward in the midst of that we need to
get you a car so uh you currently have
fourteen thousand dollars and twelve
thousand dollars worth of debt did I
understand that correctly yes sir
and you don't go to work until June
I guess so currently I'm working just
part-time because I don't go to work
until June yeah yes sir so next week I
want you to go to work
like all the time
there's no reason to sit on your butt
from now till June
okay
might as well what else you doing
that is a good question yeah
all right so yeah let's do that uh
because I'm all right Jade I'm a little
bit torn okay I'm kind of thinking
a thousand dollar car and pay off all
the debt yeah I would have been kind of
thinking a four thousand dollar car and
then between now and June pay off the
rest of the debt because he works 60
hours a week between now and June at six
jobs
I kind of feel like I would go for the
cheaper car pay off the debt and then
when he starts working he can get some
time yeah
I don't know
um what are you making now I know you're
making part-time but are you making yeah
anything to add to this
what are you making now yes uh currently
I'm making now I would average out to
about
200 a week so maybe like 800 to a
thousand a month all right
um
I probably wouldn't spend more than two
or three thousand on a car yeah let's
let's go with 3 000 and put everything
else you own except one thousand dollars
so that's four out of your fourteen that
leaves you ten and I want that 10 on the
debt by the end of the day today okay
and now you had a student loan debt did
you have a small something else or just
the student loans
oh no Jesus student loans no credit
cards anything like that how many loans
are there separate loans
uh I believe it's two because compromise
as comprised of two loans right and what
are their amounts
let me check on that for you sir
[Music]
actually no no I'm sorry I'm sorry
I thought I said it was it's all one
amount yeah okay well just pay ten
thousand dollars against it that should
leave you a balance of about two
thousand dollars that should leave you
three thousand dollars for a car and one
thousand dollars left over in savings
for a miniature starter emergency fund
and then you get out there kick butt and
take names for the next 60 days pay that
2 000 off so by the time you step into
the job you're debt free then you finish
your emergency fund by the end of the
summer of three to six months of
expenses so it's September you're
driving a three thousand dollar paid for
car you have zero debt and fifteen
thousand dollars in the bank in
September I like your life then but this
is the life that a hustler is going to
go get and that means you are working
five to six jobs between now and the
time you take this big job because you
need money
and that's where you get money mm-hmm
that making sense it's making sense to
me yeah I like that plan yeah and I
wouldn't spend it I mean and here's the
thing you don't want to drive a three
thousand dollar car very long so by
Christmas after you finish your
emergency fund I want you to save up and
uh buy you about a ten thousand dollar
car yeah because the good news about a
three thousand dollar car is it's not
going to go down much in value it's
pretty well done
it's pretty it might be worth four
thousand by Christmas if you take care
of it if you buy it right you know so
yeah I would buy that and then take that
car and put seven thousand cash with it
above your emergency fund be driving a
ten thousand dollar car by Christmas 100
debt free with fifteen thousand in
savings for emergencies and we're debt
free and it's not even been a year at
Christmas because this is March
it's a lot you can do in in eight to
nine months you can change your life
change your money if you're a hustler
yeah but hustling Hustler means you're
hustling I'm not just talking about it
you can't just talk about it you got to
do it there's that
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
a home is one of the biggest decisions
of your life you need a partner like
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is one of
the highest rated lenders in the country
and their Ramsay trusted because they do
what's right for you Churchill works
with you to build a mortgage the Ramsay
way one that doesn't bust your budget
sets you up for financial success and
helps you get out of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
foreign
Warsaw Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us hey if
you you guys are enjoying the show you
can help us and many of you have been
doing this we know because our numbers
are way up
the other day we were number 16th on the
Apple podcast list of all podcasts in
the world which there are over two and a
half million of them
and uh our guys our guys in in our
marketing team are really upset that
we're only 16th they think we ought to
be in the top ten I agree I think 16 is
working for us though so I'm good with
that but actually that's moving we're
moving on up as they say yes and so uh
but you guys here if you want to help us
out and say thank you for the service
that this show provides to your life we
would appreciate it it's real simple
share it with someone click the share
button or share a link or just tell
somebody where you heard about it and
you can subscribe click the follow the
Subscribe button whether it's a a
podcast whether it's a YouTube whatever
it is and you can leave a five-star
review one Stars aren't helpful your
mother said if you don't have anything
nice to say don't say anything at all
so just go with Mom's advice and leave a
five-star review they're helpful all
three of those things together actually
do move the needle and it causes the
algorithms to push the show forward as a
suggested item in people's you know how
these things magically appear that you
were thinking about yeah well we're one
of those yes and so um that that's how
that's our biggest because we're not
like um spending so much money on
marketing that we have our own stadium
right right I know some I know some some
banks said yeah no no I'm sorry excuse
me I got allergies um but the uh I
didn't spend 300 million on uh marketing
like so much and so um
instead you guys have to tell people
about us because you're like our
marketing engine so help us out uh help
us out and that's a way you can say
thank you to do that so thanks for
hanging out all right uh Carly's with us
in Montgomery Alabama hey Carly how can
we help
hey Dave
um and I agree y'all should be in the
top ten absolutely all right we got
Carly's vote somebody tell Apple Carly
said okay
my question is should my husband and I
cancel the whole life insurance policy
that we have
I think I think I know the answer well I
we do suggest term life insurance but I
would make sure that the term life
insurance is in place for both of you uh
before you cancel your Whole Life
policies so have you already gotten with
somebody like Xander to price it out and
get it in place
did you say bander yeah this is Anderson
we recommend for term insurance
and have for 25 years they got the best
prices on the planet yeah they're great
okay I'm taking notes and no we have
term life
we have it through the same
person that we have the whole life whole
life what's the company correct
it's the Northwestern Mutual okay all
right cool so here's what you're going
to find out the reason we have it is
because we know we personally know yeah
I'm sure that's the only reason you
would buy that crap yeah right and
so you know wanted
a date which I know that's awesome Dave
how you made some of your money was in
real estate and it sounded great but
here it is a year later and they're
wanting us to pay eight thousand dollars
again which we didn't we didn't realize
that was an annual payment of eight
thousand dollars we've already paid that
one time and it's due again at the end
of the month yeah okay yeah you need to
get
um number one when you go to Xander
you're going to find that Northwestern
Mutual is one of the most expensive
whole life companies out there one of
the worst ones translation and their
term insurance is as bad as their whole
life so you're going to be able to cut
your cost for the same exact policy on
the term probably in half
your term insurance is super expensive
term insurance too okay but we need to
get that in place because I don't want
one of you to die with no insurance
because you cancel all your policies and
then it takes three months to get your
new ones in place right car wreck
happens in the interim little kids are
hungry I don't like that plan
okay number one start new policy new
policy Xander
z-a-n-d-e-r-insurance.com go there it'll
get you a quick easy quote when you get
the quote back you're going to go Dad
come Ramsay yeah okay so there you go
and uh and you're you should have a good
rule of thumb is 10 to 12 times your
income on you 10 to 12 times your
husband's income on him what do you make
47 roughly before side hustles I want
you to I want you to price 500 and 600
on you
at 15-year level fixed how old are you
I'm 25. good it's going to be the cost
of a pizza yeah super cheap it's really
cheap and just put it on a monthly plan
and just pay it monthly okay it's real
easy it comes out of your checking
account goes right in your budget now
what's your husband make
45 okay so same thing
so let's say we put 600 on him let me
show you how this works all right this
is why we do this it's important to not
do it because I should do it but
important otherwise that you understand
okay so 600 000 invested in good mutual
funds the stock market has averaged 11.8
percent since it began so if you get an
average rate of return or less let's
make it round so it's real easy on the
radio uh sixty thousand six hundred
thousand let's say that you made ten
percent on that your husband died you
got 600 000 you put it in a mutual fund
it makes ten percent and that makes you
get an income of ten percent of six
hundred thousand does that sound like
sixty thousand a year to you Carly
honestly it kind of went over my head
okay six hundred thousand I'm trying to
follow that's okay six hundred thousand
dollars on your husband and he passes
away
the insurance company sends you a check
for six hundred thousand dollars
you take that check
put it in mutual funds with a
smartvester pro because you listen to
this show okay
okay if the mutual funds made ten
percent a year
10 percent of six hundred thousand
is sixty thousand
did did we do it that time did we make
it
you with me
I'm with you okay so if you got sixty
thousand dollars a year coming in and
the six hundred thousand didn't move
they're just sending you the income off
of it you get that forever
you following me
so your husband's income that was lost
when he passed away in our bad story
here
has been replaced with a sixty thousand
dollar income from Investments because
you had the proper amount of term
insurance in place
did that make sense to you
yes sir that's the purpose of it is to
replace it and not not eat it up so it
just sits there and runs it's just the
goose that's laying a golden egg every
year that's 60 Grand and so I try to not
buy too much life insurance I don't want
to buy I don't want to be worth more
debt than alive because then I have to I
have to sleep with one eye open with
Sharon Ramsey right
okay so you need to get 600 on you 600
on him or 500 right in there that range
for that reason when that's in place
you'll want to drop that other stuff by
the way if you don't pay the eight
thousand dollar payment it'll take them
uh 60 to 90 days to get around to
canceling you Mac minimum of 30 days
okay so yeah how much is your term
insurance currently professional how
much is your current term insurance not
how much coverage is it
I don't know I want to say maybe a
million
for both of us of term a million each or
500 and 500. no no 500 I think 500 and
500. well that sounds like the proper
amount and all you're going to end up
doing is replacing that because you're
going to find it's too expensive
okay
you're gonna find again you're going to
be able to do that 500 and 500 for a lot
less than you're paying now assuming
they have a 15-year term and you're
comparing Apples to Apples but that's
what you need to do right there kiddo
that's a good point you made Dave I
think a lot of people don't realize that
the purpose of life insurance is to
replace income because I know I've
talked to a lot of folks in our FPU
class and they say oh I've got insurance
through my work and for most people it's
not enough to cover income one year of
income yeah something like that so check
your insurances make sure you're covered
to the right amount check with Xander
insurance it's just not that much it's
really not I'm basically not a lot of
money to put 500k on a 25 year old
especially when you're healthy yeah and
man if something happens
it's a big deal peace of mind you're
just irresponsible be out there walking
around without it so people get this
stuff in place this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you are here hey
with debt payments out there at an
all-time high General Credit Card debts
at an all-time high car debt is at an
all-time student loan debt is an
all-time high I wish one of these would
fail to be at an all-time high but none
of them have so far
uh you people continue to keep us
employed I'm just saying
I mean like me and Jenny Craig we got a
big job job security there's a lot to do
here
debt payments are everywhere and now
with inflation being out of control and
other stuff happening all over the
culture more and more of your paycheck
being stolen
well you shouldn't have to live with
this kind of stress
if you want to change and something
doesn't need to change you know that
you have to have that moment where you
say I've had it I'm not living like this
anymore
if you've had that moment and you are
really ready to make the
go through the pain of changing to stop
the pain of this financial anxiety Then
you need the opposite of financial
anxiety and that's called Financial
Peace
University it's our nine lesson nine
week course that'll teach you how to
beat debt build wealth and become
outrageously generous
it's everything you wish you'd learned
about how to handle money nearly 10
million people have taken Financial
Peace University if you're ready to
change we can help
I can't make you do it but I can show
you how if you're ready
Financial Peace University
ramseysolutions.com
FPU
FPU Julie's next in Columbus Ohio hi
Julie welcome to the uh Ramsey Show
hi thank you appreciate you taking my
call sure how can we help
so my husband and I are working on the
steps and we are on step two
um and now we're ready to we differ a
little bit in our viewpoints as far as
what we should do next so we're both 50
years old and I want to focus any extra
money on any of our debts or all of our
debts the credit cards and such and he
has just started a job that now has the
opportunity for some retirement funds
and he's never he does not have any sort
of retirement or pensions up to this
point
so he wants to focus all the extra money
he can into building the retirement fund
for himself okay so you didn't really
tell us accurately then you said my
husband and I were wanting to work the
baby steps because the truth is you are
wanting to work the baby steps he's not
yeah you guys are not on the same page
right yeah you're wanting to be baby
step two everything in on getting out of
debt because when you get out of debt
then you've got plenty of money to put
money into retirement and yeah you've
got some catching up to do at 55 but you
can do it but the fastest way to do is
get out of debt so you're ready to do it
he's wanting to do his plan
yes hey so I guess
I'm sorry go ahead are you guys
combining your money the way you talked
about
your retirement you said hey I heard you
say his retirement or in his I just want
to see where you guys are in that area
and so I basically he is giving me some
towards the bills at this point and I'm
finally getting him
um with the idea of you have to let me
take over because he struggles with it
nope so both are wrong you know you're
both wrong yeah
you guys need to overhaul this entire
situation because the fact of the matter
is you're not on the same page you want
to do this he wants to do something else
you guys are not sharing your money
you're on separate game plans thing one
is
getting United on just marriage which in
this case involves your money and I'm
wondering for you if you were to speak
to him and say hey I talked to some
Knuckleheads on the radio today and they
said that we need to combine our
finances that's step one what would he
say to that
and what do you say to that
I'm I'm game for it um we had done that
in the past and
um we we were fine with it I managed
paying the bills I kept him informed of
everything
um he was starting a new job he has kind
of gone a bit overboard on spending and
opened up a bunch of new credit cards
and I do feel like he's just gotten
embarrassed as to where he is at this
point yeah
he can't handle it yeah when I do stuff
stupid It embarrasses me too so I
understand
yeah yeah because I mean what he's doing
is wrong of course he's embarrassed of
course he feels foolish because he's
been foolish
that'll make you feel foolish being
foolish I've done it I know
so yeah so here's the thing
let's back up three steps like we said
and like Jade said and reset so re a
proper okay number one the advice we're
giving you is not Theory we've done this
with millions of people and have led
people to become Millionaires and retire
with dignity with a paid for house let's
just say that's the goal okay
let's say that by 70 you're a
millionaire and you have a paid for
house that's our goal what is the
fastest right way
to get there
okay that's a question you and your
husband both need to answer now we have
proven
by teaching and walking with thousands
and millions of families now that the
fastest right way to get there is a
process that we call the baby steps
where you first save a thousand dollars
and baby step one baby step two is you
pay off all of your debts except your
home and because your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income and
when you give it all to Ford Motor
Company and MasterCard you don't have it
anymore they do
and so you have to stop giving your
money away to these idiots that are
taking your money but you gave it to
them so you have to stop it that's
called debt reduction right we're
getting out of debt now when you don't
have any debt payments but your house
anymore that'll feel pretty good won't
it ask him that and I'm asking you that
Julie that'll feel good won't he say yes
yeah and the credit cards that he just
took out we're going to have a little
plastic surgery Party by candlelight
tonight
chop those puppies up
a plastic to me at Julie's house okay
now once we're out of debt we build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and then we start saving 15
percent of our household income into
retirement if you do that if you follow
that how much debt do you have
not counting your hands right
not counting the house but we're at
about 121 000. on what
um credit cards and a truck payment for
him how much do you owe on his truck
20 000. and what's your household income
well a hundred thousand okay
got a lot of truck
yeah you got it new so part of this is
this 55 year old little boy is going to
grow up and be a man now and put his
future in his sights and not his weekend
that's part of what's going on here this
guy the way the way you have described
him in this call he just goes and does
whatever the flip he wants as if there's
no consequences
and then he's embarrassed
okay so now we got to stop this and we
got to undo a bunch of it now then the
last part of this whole story is the two
of you are going to decide together
every month before the month begins on
paper on purpose where every dollar is
going to go to accomplish the goals in
those baby steps so that we can retire
with a paid for house and a million
dollars
and if we are saying that's the goal and
whatever we've got to do to get to that
goal that means we're going to sell
everything in sight we're not going to
see the inside of a restaurant unless
we're working there we're not going on
vacation because we're broke people
we're 55 years old and 120 000 in debt
and no money and scared about retirement
and we're going to do something about it
and this is who you become and the two
of you together join arms and say we're
going to be grown-ups it's not thank God
it's Friday oh God it's Monday it's
we're going to retire in 15 years from
now with some dadgum money because we
changed our lives now if you're ready to
do that really I can help you that's
what we do but if you're going to keep
playing around playing footsie with this
and he's going to keep running around
like a weekend little boy Huey Lewis in
the news living for the weekend not
gonna work for me I can't help you but
if you want to do all this stuff we'll
put you through Financial Peace
University you hold on you can tell
Austin if you want to do it we'll pay
for you to go through the class you and
your husband that I just picked on this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five hey if you are a brand new
listener and as we have said there are
many of you out there that are brand new
we appreciate that and if you want to
learn how this Ramsay stuff works some
of this uh inside baseball where we're
saying stuff like baby steps and we're
saying things like debts snowballs and
all that stuff go to ramsaysolutions.com
click on the get started button and
we'll help you figure out the next best
step in your financial journey we'll let
you know where you are in the baby steps
and what you do from here exactly what
to do
ramseysolutions.com click get started
Jade it is worth you and I taking a
moment
and explaining that the thing that we
have discovered at Ramsey
30 years ago
that has made all the difference in the
world in people's lives
is not the
tactical what to do with money stuff
it's the understanding that personal
finance is 80 percent Behavior yes
20 head knowledge the mathematics of
becoming a multi-millionaire
are learned by the sixth grade
spend less than you make oh Dave
I mean that requires self-control
yeah so the problem is the guy in my
mirror yeah if I can control this goober
he can be skinny and Rich but goober has
a problem his name is Dave
and you know you gotta you guys gotta
figure that out because that's the bad
news the bad news is I'm the problem the
great news is I'm the solution it's a
decision yeah you just have to decide
you want to do something different
because you kind of already know what to
do we'll give you the fine tuning and
we'll show you the but we don't sell
magic beans here jack is not here yeah
Dave's here
you have to do the work there's no easy
there's no easy button to push on this
there's no magic pill like you said
you're gonna have to look at what you're
doing and if you want a different
situation you're gonna have to do
something different if you want to
experience change you're going to have
to change your habits that's how it
works you can't just keep doing the same
thing and think you're going to get the
same result and what I love about how we
teach money is it is it is they are very
simple Concepts Dave
very simple live on less than you make
yeah get on a written plan and they're
counter-cultural absolutely because most
people spend more than they make yes get
out of that and stay out of that that's
counter cultural because most people
believe you have to have debt to win and
actually the data says and 30 plus years
of doing this leading more people into
millionaire status than anybody else
tells me and tells you and tells us at
Ramsey that the proper way to do this is
get out of debt because your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income yeah and so you've got to pay a
price to win you've got to live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else there's a price to
be paid to get out of the mess that you
made yeah and and let us be like you
said it is counter-cultural because
everything out there is telling you to
be reliant on something else the credit
system is telling you you need credit
you need us you can't exist in this
world without us and the government
tells us the same thing you need us you
can't exist in this world and pay off
your debts you need us everything is
give given us the message that we cannot
be Reliant upon our own volition you
know we we can't handle our money
ourselves we can't do anything on our
own and that's completely false you
actually do have control over how you
spend your money you actually do have
control over the decisions that you make
that's false and part of it is whether
you're 25 or whether you're 55 is
growing up absolutely and one definition
of maturity
is the ability to delay pleasure
adults devise a plan and follow it
children
do what feels good yep and I don't care
how old you are if all you do is go on
your feelings
then you're a child absolutely you have
to say all right there's a destination
over here
what has to be true that is not true
today so that I'm that person over there
instead of the person I am right now
come on that you are preaching to the
choir right now because some of you know
my story and some of you don't my
husband Sam and I had
half a million dollars in debt for lack
of a better word 460 000 a bit and I
distinctly remember the moment Dave
where I thought if if we don't do
something about this I will never have
any of the things that I wanted out of
life yeah financially with the family I
I want to be 20 I want to be 30 pounds
lighter yeah okay good is this a wish
or is this a goal right
if it's a goal
then you say all right when do I want to
be 30 pounds lighter
all right win three months from now okay
now we have a goal now then you have to
ask yourself okay what has to be true
that's not true now
and in my case it's less Donuts fat boy
I mean you know get away from the
chocolate donuts boy because the guy
that the guy that's got a six-pack and I
got a keg he's you know he's not doing
the donuts no he's so you gotta you know
okay something has to change and I gotta
like the idea of being thinner more than
I like the instantaneous gratification
and Sugar Rush of a chocolate covered oh
my God I want one donut right well
practically for us it was you don't make
enough money so you need to earn more
money what has to be true that's not
true now I need more money I care too
much about what other people think so
I'm buying stuff I can't afford to
impress these people gotta change that
I'm trying to drag along a spouse who's
not getting going along with this my
spouse keeps running off and doing this
other crap and I'm trying to do this
well what's what has to be true what has
to be true is you guys got to get on the
same page because that's a key data
point in people who win with money they
control their behaviors adults devise a
plan
and follow it children
we I deserve I deserve a new car call
the wambulance
seriously children do what feels good
now I've been both probably today
but certainly in my life right I mean
there are times there's a higher more
noble Dave and then there are times I
just want one you know don't tell me I
can't do it I deserve it I work hard
I'll shut up
like nobody else works hard but you
right I deserve to be deeply in debt and
get a truck I can't afford because I
work hard what you you work hard so you
deserve to be broke I don't understand
how dumb a butt statement is that but
people say stupid butt stuff like that
right it's crazy so you've got to look
out there and say what am I willing to
become so that I am over that person
over there what am I willing to give up
what has to be true that's not true
today we have to be working together we
have to be living on less than we make
we have to be doing a written budget we
have to be cutting up the credit cards
we have to be getting rid of the whole
life policy we're selling a stupid car
we can't afford we're we're not going on
vacation We're not gonna go out to eat
every night we're freaking broke people
we're not doing this anymore and you
start talking to yourself and going but
not for long yeah not for long as for me
and my house we're not going to live
like this we're going to live like no
one else so that later I gotta you know
where I eat out now any dead gun place I
want to you know I recommend you now
from the left to the right I don't start
with the price I start with what I
freaking want to eat you know why
because I did all this stuff for the
last 30 years and it works Come On Dave
be honest you don't even have to look to
the right
I don't you don't know you just look at
it the only time I do is on the wine
because some of it's really expensive
but
oh man I love it I can go on on and on
about this conversation because it's
true and and the thing is you've gotta
you've gotta find and look inside and
find the reason why if you don't know
why you're not gonna try period you're
gonna start and you're gonna go I heard
this guy on the radio Dave and I heard
Jay talking and you get all excited
about it but then when the rubber meets
the road you don't do it you quit you
have to let me tell you you're gonna get
tired yeah and you're gonna be scared
and you're gonna get dirt under your
fingernails because you work so much
so that later you don't have to yep and
it changes you you know where you want
to be working extra jobs when you're 70
or when you're 27 okay
because social insecurity is not going
to cut it baby
you talk about too much month at the end
of the money
broke old people living on Social
Security this ain't fun
once you sign up for a different trip
boys and girls
[Music]
it's all about you the person in your
mirror you can do it we believe in you
and we'll hold you to it this is the
Ramsey Show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jason is with us in Sacramento hi Jason
welcome to the Ramsay show
good afternoon Jaden Dave
um so my financial plan has 80d I I'm
kind of all over the place with my baby
clips
why
um well I've been listening to you guys
for a number of years I follow you
online I haven't actually signed up for
financial peace but I did register to
become a coordinator
um we paid off our basic debt we paid
off for car debt we have our emergency
fund
um
we we have our you know three to six
months
in savings so I think we're on four five
and six and then we just kind of went
okay we're good you have no debt at all
except your house
uh well you're gonna yell at me I have 2
000 in credit card debt that we roll not
roll over but our monthly expense no
wait were you listening okay
yeah I was Dave okay so you already got
yelled at a little bit for those
listening weeks I will get yelled at yes
for those listening the past segment we
we yelled at some folks but here's the
thing Jason you you said you're a long
time listener you said you understand
the program you're choosing to do
something different
you're choosing to work your own plan
but you called us and I'm going to tell
you to cut up the credit cards and I'm
also going to look at you with a with a
smart look on my face and wonder why you
are doing that
uh honestly the way it started for years
I was cash only before before your show
um and then we we weren't in a position
where we wanted to pay cash for a car
because it would have cut too much into
our savings
and we we just we had no credit so yeah
I'm sorry
whoa whoa stop okay I've heard about
your plan
and you know about our plan what's your
question yeah
uh I'm somewhere between steps four five
and six no you're not and I'm just
trying to figure out you're not working
this you're not working the baby steps
but what's your question then
okay what's your question you want me to
pay off the credit card debt no what is
your question 45 and six I want you to
tell me what your question is
are you asking what baby step you're on
um I in my head I
hear him baby step two you're in baby
step four of your head
but you have a different plan of baby
steps than we do
so no you're in baby step two you still
have credit card debt and you still have
credit cards so you still have consumer
that 100 debt free with no credit cards
and debit cards in your pocket that you
use your money is baby step two
and you're not there okay and it's
inconvenient to pay cash for my car
because I don't want to limit my savings
is your plan
not a millionaire plan not a wealthy
person plan
a middle-class person's plan I'm going
to leave money in savings at three to
five percent and borrow money to buy a
car at eight to twelve percent well
that's a freaking genius move
I mean so you what you've got to decide
Jason is and it's Okay We're not gonna
be mad at you but don't walk around
telling people that you're on a baby
step because you're not doing any of it
you're doing your deal
and one of my friends who's a a wealthy
guy that still had been playing around
with that and stuff I was I was actually
speaking at an event and he and I ended
up having lunch after the event uh in
another city and he said you know I
finally did all your stuff and I'm like
what do you mean what do you mean you
did all my stuff because you ain't done
nothing I said right we've been friends
a long time and you've been stupid the
whole time unknown and he goes well what
do you mean he goes I said man you know
it's okay I still love you you're still
my friend but you don't do our stuff and
he goes no I really do I said what do
you mean he goes I did it all I'm 100
debt free I've got my emergency fund I
matter of fact I'm paying off my house
uh I paid off my house two weeks ago oh
wow and so he's baby step seven right he
did it all and I said what changed and
he goes well I finally had to submit
myself
to the process that you laid out because
I kept thinking I could figure it out
faster than you could and I forgot that
you're the guy on this yeah and he go
and he goes and oh by the way when
you're doing the stuff in my world
you're going to submit yourself to my
way because I'm the expert there and I'm
like I'm in smart guy you know I mean
but you have to you know you got to find
a proven thing and then do the thing not
ish it I mean ish is a wish Dave you're
on the radio
we're on the radio what is a number 16
show
Financial expert
and when we I'll talk about myself from
before I got here I listened to you and
I listen to the other personalities
because I'm like they're in that
position they understand money I'm a lay
person I'm just trying to scratch and
Claw my way do I really think that I've
got a better method or am I going to go
for the folks if that have helped
millions of other people do it and if
you do it's okay
go through that go do that it's okay we
don't have to be mad about it I'm not
mad about it but here's the thing if you
want to do the stuff we're talking about
do it yeah and it'll work
it's a proven
process screwing around with it and
isching it
you know I'm ish I'm Ramsey ish
yeah it just doesn't work Jason it
doesn't work my brother
thank you okay friends and you keep your
car payment and your credit cards and
we'll still be friends and I'll just be
your Rich friend
and so I get a little frustrated with it
Dave I'm not gonna lie well it is it is
frustrating but you know it's just but
but it it but the frustration is not
because of like we're insulted because
we want we love you yeah we love you we
want you to win
we want you to do better yeah and we
want you to turn the corner on this
stuff and so but it's like a lot of
things in life have you ever had a
friend that was you know trying to quit
drinking or trying to quit misbehaving
and and you wanted it for them more than
they wanted it for them yes yeah that
that's the frustrating part because we
we see it and we know and we get it and
welcome to the Ramsay show yeah so there
you go yeah cause we love you and we I
mean but everybody's got stupid people
that they love I mean you know we all do
and I'm the stupid people that other
people
I love Dave but he's crazier than a bean
you know I mean it's okay that's all
right I'm good with that
you don't have to be we don't have to be
mad about it we don't have to troll
somebody about it or something like that
it's just a matter of are you going to
do this stuff it's like I hired a
personal trainer and he's got a six-pack
I got a keg right and um I'm like and he
tells me what I need to eat now if I
don't eat what he says
then I'm I'm not gonna look like him
well it's one thing to not eat what he
says but don't sit there and argue with
him about it I I'm actually a nutrition
specialist check out this belly it
proves it
right some of the folks obviously
previously taking in more food than you
so I I am I know more than you this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America our question
of the day sponsored by neighborly your
hub for Home Services don't wait until
the AC or other Home systems go out this
summer neighborly is your key to staying
on top of your home maintenance needs
don't wait on emergencies find Reliable
home service providers like air serve Mr
Appliance and Mr Rooter Plumbing lots of
others at neighborly.com keeps your
house running like clockwork today's
question of the day comes from Harry in
Georgia he says I have a budget in place
and I'm using the debt snowball would
you recommend consolidating all of the
debt into one giant personal loan I also
have a total of fifty thousand dollars
between five credit cards a personal
loan and an appliance loan I also have a
ton of equity in my home so I was
wondering about doing a home equity loan
which could give me tax a savings on the
interest should I just keep it status
quo for now and continue the snowball or
do debt consolidation loan overall I'm
just looking to expedite debt
elimination all right
so
the debt snowball I would not call
status quo I think that it is the most
effective way to pay off debt and it's
been proven there's been some studies I
know Harvard published a paper about why
the debt snowball actually works and
that it works it's the most successful
way to pay off debt so I would not
recommend
um Harry doing a consolidation or a
HELOC and I it sounds like you're just
like trying to think of ways to get this
debt out of your life and again there's
no easy button you're gonna have to list
your debts from smallest to largest and
work to pay this off if you do a debt
consolidation loan there's a couple of
things there you're not paying it off
you're just clumping it all together
moving it all together and actually
there's studies that show that when you
do that your brain thinks that you have
less debt and you go back into debt
again because you've moved it all into
one payment you haven't actually paid it
off not to mention when it comes to debt
consolidation you know they're doing for
you what you can do yourself they're
they're making deals with these
companies you can do that you're
yourself you can set up payment
schedules you can do all of that
yourself you don't have to pay somebody
to do it for you and a lot of times the
interest rate when you get debt
consolidation is no better because it's
based on your credit and if you have
ruined credit then you're not going to
have a better credit rate on that debt
consolidation loan anyway a better uh
interest rate
so I wouldn't do that and then talking
about the HELOC again you're just moving
debt and now you're moving it into your
home mortgage so you really want to put
your home on the hook for your debt I
would not do that home equity line of
credit is what he's talking about for
somebody who's listening the first time
that you don't understand what that is
it's basically a line of credit that you
pull out on your home and uh he wants to
use that to pay off his debt a terrible
idea you're not paying it off you're
just moving it into your mortgage not a
good idea let's use the debt snowball
again list your debt smallest to largest
make minimum payments on all of the debt
and then take any and all extra money
that you can and throw it at the
smallest debt until it's paid off gotta
go quickly gotta use intensity for this
and then when that smallest set is paid
off the money is freed up and you throw
it on the next smallest debt and then
you do that again and before you know it
you've got a nice snowball going and
that is how you pay off debt and let me
tell you something you want to do that
you need to do it smallest to largest so
that you feel those wins uh Harry
because when you feel the wind of paying
off that smallest debt you're going to
be like wait a minute wait a minute I
can do this this works and then you're
going to go to the next one and you feel
that motivation once you begin starting
and once you start feeling the momentum
that comes with the snowball so just do
it just walk yourself through the
process you're going to be better for it
you're going to allow yourself to feel
the pain of your debt when you do the
snowball you feel it because you have to
work to make it happen you're not just
rolling it into some other loan you're
not rolling it into your mortgage you're
not taking the easy way out
Harry the thing you got to remember is
this
you have a block of debt that's fifty
thousand dollars
if that block of debt is a debt
consolidation loan it's still fifty
thousand dollars
if that block of debt is a HELOC it's
still fifty thousand dollars
there's only one way to get rid of fifty
thousand dollars
pay fifty thousand dollars
there is no none of these programs all
they do is lower the amount of interest
and interest is not your problem
spending more than you make is your
problem
not increasing your income enough to
throw at the fifty thousand dollars is
your problem you need to come up with
five thousand dollars a month for ten
months
because you work so much that you can't
breathe
great place to go when you're broke to
work the interest rate on your HELOC is
versus the interest rate on your debt
snowball is not going to fix the problem
no you need fifty thousand dollars
that's the problem you're concentrating
on the wrong end of the iceberg
the interest is just sticking up above
the water there's a big Iceberg below
the surface
it's 50
000 dollars that's the problem and I
want to write off the interest
as having a HELOC you're not riding off
the entrance you don't you don't write
off the interest on a HELOC you know why
only 13 percent of Americans itemize
87 percent take the standard deduction
good point so you probably are taking a
standard deduction which means you don't
get to write off the interest because
you already took your standard deduction
if you are one of the 13 WHO itemize you
probably are not itemizing this this
anyway and it's not that big a deal I
mean the interest let's say it's ten
percent off fifty thousand dollars is
five thousand dollars you know what that
saves you in taxes 1250 bucks 1250 bucks
in your problem right fifty thousand
dollars is your problem quit trying to
trick your way out of this come up with
fifty thousand dollars that's how you do
it and the debt snowball leads you
through that process and keeps you
moving but you've got to concentrate you
need five thousand dollars a month extra
for 10 months or twenty five hundred
dollars a month extra for 20 months and
that gets rid of your problem not a
little bit of savings on interest or
some faux tax write-off that you're not
even really taking because you're taking
a standard deduction that's what's
really going on Tara's in Kalamazoo hi
Tara how are you
making my call certainly how can we help
my husband and I are about 35 and we
have one kid and one on the way we have
about two hundred thousand dollars left
on our mortgage which is at a 2.375 rate
it was originally a 15-year we have 12
left on it we have no other debt about
60 000 in cash we have about 500 000 in
Investments with one 401K that we max
out each year
we have 140 000 in short-term treasuries
like ions and t-bills how much was your
mortgage again
um it was originally was about two now
what is it today
we have 200 left
and you have 140 and I bonds and 60 000
laying around in cash
yes why do you still have a mortgage
well that's what my question is around
is
treasuries
we're curious if we should take
advantage of our current position
um seeking funding low duration like a
17-week
um TiVo and put like all of our 200. I
might get any money on that stuff if I
were you I would be mortgage free today
you're not making any money on that
stuff you need to roll out the actual
math that you're talking about here and
how many dollars it results in it's not
spit
you're not getting wealthy with this
yeah I mean you actually take 140 000
and multiply it times that
I mean you can't even go out to eat
it's not real money you're just playing
a math game you're trying to do this
with intellect
and and if you actually running out the
nominal dollars that are the resulting
here you're not making it you're not
Arbitrage in your house into T bills and
making any spread
it's it's the the difference is a joke
mathematically I mean it's a couple
thousand bucks
it's not going to make you rich you're
playing games with stuff that's not
going to make you rich you can pay off
your house today
that'll make you rich yeah keep some
money aside for three to six months yeah
three to six months of expenses and
emergencies no other debt and liquidate
everything that's non-retirement and pay
this house off this week that's what I
would do
definitely not borrowing on my home to
invest in t bills
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones to Triple eight eight two
five five two two five Angie's in San
Bernardino hi Angie welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Ramsey what an honor to talk to you both
thank you so much for taking our call
today our pleasure how can we help
okay so I'm hoping you can help us out
my beautiful husband and I cannot agree
what to do with a rental property that
we have my hubby is uh pretty concerned
about the capital gains and the
recapture of depreciation that we would
pay we would have to pay if we sell it
and I on the other hand I think it's a
really good time to sell and I think
this money would change our lives we
would pay off our home we would invest a
little more in our roths
um and maybe do a small home renovation
um so and eventually like you mentioned
before you read the menu from left to
right I can't wait to get there so
um we are humbly asking for your opinion
um I should disclose something and no
pressure okay no pressure at all but he
did say that if you said that we sell
that he's going to sell so go ahead and
tell him to sell no I'm sorry
I think we've been set up Jade
so the only reason he doesn't want to
sell is simply to avoid those capital
gains it's not because he just loves the
property and wants to hold on to it and
loves the cash flow
no the cash flow is very very low
unfortunately less than 500 a month and
um no we we don't particularly love it
um it was our first home but we've you
know we've been out of it for so long
and
um he is he it's almost like we can't he
can't stomach that we probably will have
to pay quite a bit of money so what how
much what's the house worth the rental
the house right now is worth about 5 30
and we owe about 220. okay
all right and so you're going to walk
out with um 300 Grand we'll call it okay
not quite but but um somewhere in there
right and your the balance on your
mortgage is what
225 okay so by the time you pay by the
time you pay capital gains and expenses
to sell the house you pay off your home
you're gonna have a little left but not
much
so I'm sorry our home that we live in
now we only owe 120. Oh Oh I thought you
said 225 okay 225 is the rental you were
correcting the 220. now I'm catching on
okay
um just 120 yeah and so yeah 100 and
let's say and so let's say 300 let's
call it 250 after some taxes and 120. so
you would have 130 125 or whatever left
over to do some other things with give
or take okay so
um here's the thing
um
let's pretend for a second the good way
to I a good way decision making tool
that I use in our house Sharon and I use
this all the time is if it was already
done would we undo it meaning sunk cost
analysis is what it's called okay and
this comes from the Harvard investment
newsletter uh where the the teacher in
the investment class would say if you
ever if you ever use what you paid for
something as your reason for keeping it
then that's using the wrong analysis
and the class was taught to yell out
some costs the only reason you keep
something is that you like what it's
going to do in the future not how we got
here
okay that's a proper analysis of an
investment but it's also a proper
analysis of possessions okay and so if
I'm looking at a boat in my driveway
that I haven't put in the lake in four
years and it's worth ten thousand
dollars and I say to myself if I had ten
thousand dollars piled in the middle of
the table instead of that boat would I
go buy that boat
and the answer is since I don't use the
boat anymore would obviously be no right
so that tells me it's time to sell the
boat that's a cost analysis if I didn't
have the boat and I had the money
instead which is what happens if you
sell it then what I would I go buy the
boat and if I and in my case we have
boats and we use them every summer we
love to ski we're a rims we're a lake
family and so if you said if I didn't
have that boat would I and I had that
money would I go buy the boat I'm like
yeah but sure what then I don't need to
sell my boat because that means I'm
because I like it it's what we're saying
so let's reverse this and say your house
has paid off
this is your to your husband okay your
house is paid off you have a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in a checking
account to do Renovations with go on a
trip with or whatever it is you
described a while ago you're gonna do
with the extra
if that were the case and you had the
opportunity to buy this property that
you don't that you currently own and you
didn't own it but you had the
opportunity to buy it and put down
you'd borrow money on your house you
take the money out of your checking
account and you go buy this house to put
down two or three hundred thousand
dollars on it 250 000 on it and and
we're gonna have a 500 cash flow and
this is the house we own would you do
that
and his answer is going to be no
he's shaking his head right now you
nailed it he's shaking his head what
he's he's shaking his head you're right
yeah he wouldn't go buy it because the
only reason he's keeping it is not
because he's in love with the future of
it he just doesn't want to give the
government any money because he hates
them and I agree
okay but I get the emotion but that's
not the reason for keeping the house the
reason for keeping the house is it
brings our it makes a better future for
us and nowhere in your description of
why he wanted to keep the house was that
that's how I knew he would sell it
that's how I knew he would sell it so
it's sold
and the only bad part about this
conversation Angie is you win
you set us up you set us up and you
still won and we knew we were set up
we all win Mr rounds
good call good call
especially my husband yo you totally
used this and you still won and we knew
it was happening so this was a great
experience we're so glad you called
oh thank you guys I love you both thank
you so much we love you darling thank
you for calling
that was good Marcus Mark is with us in
Knoxville hey Mark welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey Mr Ramsey thank you for taking my
call sure um I had uh
had an uncle pass away and uh I got uh I
was notified that I have a beneficiary
Ira in my name and inherited IRA
I was just looking at the paper yeah
yeah and uh for like it's around 56
000 and so I was just calling to see
like what I should do with it um I
talked with the person there and they
said
um I'll be taxed like I can leave it in
there it'll grow tax-free for 10 years
but then after that I'm required to take
it
um take the money out and then it'll be
taxed no it's not exactly true it has to
be liquidated it actually would be
liquidated 10 a year for 10 years
so okay an inherited IRA you have 10
years to undo it you have to do it 10 a
year so 5600 each year for 10 years
comes out and is taxed that is the
longest you can leave it in you can also
just take it all out today and pay the
taxes how old are you
um 20 26 what do you make
um I make about uh like I'm on contract
now but like 110 Grand what do you do
I'm a software developer good for you
okay well uh we wanna honor we want to
honor your uncle's memory and what a
wonderful Legacy that he's left to you
and I'm sorry for your loss
um no thank you so are you asking what
you should do with it
yeah I'm like what uh
I didn't know because I didn't know from
like taxes should I just leave it and
let it grow
um and in there and take that minimum
like you said that I have to take out
per year and let it grow or is it like
cash out like just cash out everything
like what uh yeah do you have any debt
uh no I don't good for you very good
okay uh do you have an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
yeah I do good for you you're doing good
man
well uh I would make sure that the money
is invested in good growth stock mutual
funds
and learn about those sit down with an
investment advisor if you need one you
can find them at a smartvester pro that
we recommend at ramsaysolutions.com
clicking on smartvestor Pro and then I
would leave it you're going to be
required to move 10 out of a year for 10
years and be taxed on it but I'd leave
it let the government keep the
government's hand off of it as long as I
can this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today all
right folks I got a lot of questions
this time of year about taxes
we have agreed that we are ultimately
hate them uh but we got to pay them
because it's the law and we don't break
the law so there you go let's unpack a
question from one of our listeners would
Ramsey smart tax software give me a
lower tax bill than TurboTax
I doubt it I wouldn't count on it to
give you a lower tax bill
um tax software is tax software the only
difference is what you pay for and how
easy it is to use it should give you
assuming both of them are reasonably
written software that they should give
both give you a similar result
uh
Ramsay smart taxes powered by a company
called tax Slayer who's been around for
over 50 years and you can count on the
software to be accurate and up to date I
think Turbo Tax would be accurate and up
to date it's a little wacky a little
wonky to use and it's one of the reasons
we did smart tax because it's owned by
Intuit
which is rocket mortgage and QuickBooks
and lots and lots and lots and lots of
credit cards yeah so their whole reason
for doing Turbo Tax is to try to get
your name and use it to sell you debt
products so obviously Ramsay smart tax
is not going to do that it's just a
simple software you pay a few bucks and
you do your taxes it's no big deal but I
think the tax you know is you know even
though uh Turbo Tax is the evil empire
uh we're also gonna not say lies about
them and that I think I think their tax
software is fine I think it does a
reasonably good job and I don't think
you're going to find anything
particularly different about it in terms
of the result like do I get a higher
refund with Ramsey no no I don't think
so not if not if both of them are
operating properly yeah they should do
that so ramseysolutions.com smart tax if
you don't want to be shoveled debt
products while you're trying to do your
thing the other thing is we're not all
the forms are included and there's no
like upcharge gotchas you want some
fries with that you want some fries with
that we don't we don't do that uh we
just the thing just works and you pay
one fee and you get it it's real simple
real clean
ramseysolutions.com smart techs if you
want to just keep your life simple but
yeah both both are accurate open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Vicki is in Las Vegas hi Vicky
how are you
hi I'm good thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
Ben and I both have long-term care
insurance
and recently I got a letter saying that
I could increase the
um the benefit for an additional charge
for my premium
it doesn't seem significant for on
either and I just wondered what your
feeling was do you just stick with a
long-term policy that you have I mean
it's with the same company but they
every three years they send you this
offer I turned it down the last three
years so if I turn it down this time
they won't offer to me again
okay so how much is your coverage
we have um
three years and it's about
so just a little over a hundred eighty
thousand dollars have you shopped around
and looked at Long-Term Care nursing
home or whatever process you're going to
use and can you do that for sixty
thousand dollars in your area
no you cannot it seems to me like it
would be uh like the max they pay a day
is 165 000 and it seemed to me like it
was going to be boring
it was going to be what 250. no no I'm
talking about per year
um no I think it'd be closer to about 80
000. okay so you have 60 000 you have 60
000 per year for three years and you
think it's going to take 80 000 per year
for three years right but the increase
that they're off
okay so it's not significant and it's
and then it costs an extra twenty
dollars a month on the policy
okay all right and do you have any money
uh we have our home is uh worth about
nine hundred thousand and we
can be mutual funds good for you and we
have we have we have tension and Social
Security that adds up to about 120 000
years so really we don't need our money
here's the here's the thing okay here's
what you here's your way you pose the
question back to yourself and it'll tell
you what to do
um okay do I want to take twenty
thousand dollars a year worth of risk
for three years
sixty thousand dollars total exposure
because it's gonna take eighty but you
got 60 coverage right right do I want to
take a sixty thousand dollar exposure
for twenty dollars a month and get rid
of some of it or do I wanna with my 700
000 be very comfortable that I can cover
that 60.
okay you don't take the increase
you self-insure it with a 700 because
you're not taking that much risk
relative to the size of your nest egg
okay okay as a matter of fact you really
could self-insure the whole thing if you
wanted to drop it
well I've been on the fence about it but
thank you
thank you just not know what to do so
I've kept it yeah it's okay to keep it
but I would definitely would not
increase it but you know so again what
would you be taking on the typical
nursing home stay in America is two and
a half years that's the national average
right and you know so your exposure's
three years
at eighty thousand two hundred forty
thousand so if Papa goes into the
nursing home
you end up with a half a million dollars
When the Smoke Clears
if you self-insure through this on
average now you could it could go higher
but if it goes higher you run out of
coverage anyway because you've only got
three years of coverage
right yeah right exactly so uh it's
taking the edge off by having the policy
but I would not give them another dime
for any more coverage I think you're in
good shape financially by the way your
millionaires you did a great job very
good
great work
Paul's with us in Omaha Nebraska hey
Paul welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
really appreciate it sure how can we
help um
all right I got a uh how much house
would you buy question uh we're moving
from Omaha to uh the Pacific Northwest
to be closer to family
and
um we've got a total including uh our
retirements which this last year I
converted all into Roth we got about
600k that we could that we could spend
that would take us down and no
retirement and just our uh six month
emergency funds and the question that I
have is how much of that would you uh
spend on a house
are you talking about draining your
retirement to pay cash for a house
uh potentially some of it it's a it's a
question uh so right now like almost all
of that is basically Rock principle
because of the conversion uh this last
year how old are you guys I can take
uh I'm 34. my wife's 31.
so you're going to be penalized too
uh because of the Roth conversion
because it's all principled we could
take it without the penalties almost all
of it
what's your household income
uh well let's call it 120.
how much of the 600 is the Roth
uh total and that's about one uh it's
about 135. right now
okay so you've got 450 000 that's not in
retirement
correct okay
that's available to you the four the 450
that's left if you can take it without
penalty and then leave the other 135.
and yeah it's just it's it's so the
place that we're moving to
um it's got a pretty wide range of
houses that you can buy there anything
from you know your 250 000 serious need
of fixing up right to your Million
Dollar Plus home
that would be true in every city
I mean the fact of the matter is you can
only buy what you can afford right so
that's kind of what that's what your
parameters got to be and of course we
would say to pick something that's on a
15-year fixed rate where the income is
no more than 25 of your take-home pay so
those are the parameters we're working
in I wouldn't touch the 135 the 135k
principle I would just use the 450 if
you want to save a little bit longer to
have more save longer no quite 450 down
as a minimum it'd be nice to buy 450 000
house just pay cash that'd be Choice one
choice two is don't take out a mortgage
it's more than a fourth of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fixed with
450 down this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
look if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show but we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Jade
wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phone's a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five cc is in Indianapolis hi
CeCe welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi there thanks for checking the call
um about two years ago we paid off our
house and
um as of May 2022 we have the million
dollar net worth yay
yeah
um but I'll be honest with you I'm more
fearful now
and when we were broke
um I'm not sure what to do with this
stuff I know that we have about 430
000 in cash spread of across three Banks
and we have 650 000 in our house which
we are selling in May and then we are
taken off for about a year and a half to
two years sabbatical
so
um
I I don't know where to park this stuff
um I'm I'm fearful of thanks
um fearful of
um
you know there is a little bit of
inheritance in there so I have that
pressure of like I'm the third
generation so I don't want to mess that
up and
um we some of our money came from Real
Estate Investments but I went out of
that because I don't want the
responsibility of it when we're gone
um so I don't know what to do
foreign
how much money do you still have in real
estate just the house just the one just
just our personal house so right now at
the end of the story you got a million
dollars in cash is what you're saying
and yeah you don't you got to decide
what to do with it while you take a year
and a half off
yeah and I could potentially honestly
that all of that
of that side of in addition to we still
have my dad's house so
either a I could end up purchasing
buying my portion and buying my brother
out or my brother could buy me out so
there's another swing of money
you know how much how much would it take
to buy him out
um 200 000 to buy him out or you know
obviously 200 000 I mean so really
honestly I have closer to a million to
yeah or more yeah so I don't have a clue
what to do okay
well the only thing that's concerning me
here is is all all of your fear
because fear is one of two things okay
there's one of two things that fear
comes from all right fear is either a
reasonable reaction to an actual threat
don't touch a hot stove that'll hurt
that's good fear right don't run in the
traffic that's good fear
okay you know you know don't eat poison
that's good fear you know I mean hello
you know so that that's all good things
then there's false evidence
appearing real
there's fear of the unknown uh brought
on by I don't understand something so
I'm afraid of it I've never ridden a
bicycle so I'm afraid of bicycles I
never learned to swim and so I'm afraid
of swimming
but neither one kill you on a regular
instance you can die on a bicycle or
swimming but they don't you know they're
not there it's not like uh swallowing
rat poison okay it's like 100 fatality
rate the bicycles are not right you see
what I'm saying so but the the fear that
a child feels the first time they go in
to swim is a a fear based on the unknown
ignorance of the process not based on
the actual threat you see the difference
yes and I think that's the one you're
struggling with
okay I think you're afraid to put money
in the stock market you're afraid to put
money in the banks because you've built
up this Boogeyman thing going on that's
really not there
I've got money in Banks and I'm not
afraid
I don't think my bank is going to fail
it has nothing to do with SVP svb but
the uh uh I mean and I've got money in
the stock market and mutual funds
millions of dollars and I am not not
even my pulse rate has not even changed
okay except maybe a little bit of
excitement every now and then but anyway
but yeah
um so and when you bought your home an
example of that is there were no
guarantees when you bought the home
there was not a federal guarantee
against a loss but you did were not
afraid because you were comfortable with
your knowledge of the real estate market
just because you had walking around
since you didn't have to be a real
estate expert you're just old enough to
go man I remember when houses sold for x
and now they're selling for y and real
estate's just solid and I can be in real
estate so you're comfortable with that
one because you're comfortable with the
history and the track record and your
knowledge of it
so I I don't want you to put something
in put your money in something that
causes you to lose sleep but if you put
a million dollars aside in good mutual
funds and if it makes
uh seven eight percent ten percent you
got 70 or 100 000 a year to live off of
and not touch your million dollars while
you're on sabbatical
how do I go about I don't know anything
saying the same thing and he is in the
stock market a little bit but he's so
young and an experience that I just
can't take he's not he's not trustworthy
enough to give you to cause your fear
because he's a bad guy but he's just a
neophyte no right and he's good at what
he but he's he's only been doing it for
a year or two so that's not enough for
me okay what I want you to do so what do
I do I want you to do I want you to get
in touch with one of our smartvester
pros and that's why we tell you to work
with people with the heart of a teacher
and um
I want you to tell them what you're
struggling with
and say you've got to teach me
enough about the history of this of a
mutual fund give me a few mutual fund
examples give me there's some really
good brochures out on mutual funds that
show the history and show the stability
and you know once you study those for an
hour
if you if you can do sixth grade math
you're going to be going oh my gosh I
get it okay
um so do you think I should put all of
it and maybe when you say put all of it
while I'm wrong only if you can get
comfortable
okay I don't want you I don't want you
on a sabbatical in freak out mode
[Laughter]
what does it take you guys to live a
year while you're in the sabbatical
oh my gosh it's it's so cheap it's it's
probably thirty thousand dollars okay so
here's the thing if you put a million
dollars in a a couple of banks you know
five banks and four Banks and spread
around where you've got the FDIC
coverage and you make nothing
but you sleep and you have a good
sabbatical and you pull 30 grand out to
eat on
that's okay I would rather you do that
than invest in mutual funds only because
Dave and Jade said so
okay I want you to study now so get in
touch with the smart Master Pro begin
learning but only if you can get enough
knowledge like you do about real estate
and it's not like you got to go get an
MBA in finance you just got to learn the
history of these things so and ask the
smartvester pro to give you a brochure
there's a wonderful brochure on
Investment Company of America ICA as an
example it'll teach you some of the
history it's one of the best brochures
on mutual funds I've seen it's a good
mutual fund too but but ask them to give
you the American Funds ICA brochure this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is our
co-host today this is the Ramsay show
it's a show about your life your
relationships your careers and your
money Catherine's with us in Baltimore
Maryland hi Catherine welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave hey what's up
well so we started attacking our debt
snowball like in Earnest two months ago
and to do that we're we're doing a
rental property my husband brought into
our marriage the equity would wipe out a
big chunk of our debt
um the issue is we let the renters know
at the beginning of this month we
weren't going to renew their lease and
they've stopped all Communications uh
they've got two months before the lease
terminates because they get 90 degrees
notice and our lawyer let us know that
really the only thing we can do is file
for a formal eviction but it could take
three weeks to four months and the lease
just might expire before it goes through
and so I guess my question really is
do we go forward with an eviction
process in the fees since we're planning
to sell the property anyway should we
eat the Lost payments I think my biggest
concern is that like if the renters are
already acting in bad faith that if we
bring legal action they'll not only stop
paying rent but they'll like trash the
place and then we have to pay repairs
and stuff
um
it's like 1500 bucks
okay
and so they're going to be forty five
hundred dollars into you by the time
this is up
yeah and how much of a deposit do you
have
so they're going to be three thousand
dollars into you yeah
uh the lawyer that you talk to how many
evictions has he done this year
he's done two this year well he's saying
that he's had two that have like
finished proceeding start to finish this
year which is why because when we asked
how long it would take
he like said it would go three weeks to
four months so he does this regularly
but is not successful
[Music]
we asked the
um the attorney who helped us drop like
the least paperwork so I don't know that
he does a lot of eviction I think he
just generally does rental property like
in general that's kind of what I was
thinking
so what we need is a lawyer who makes
his living or her living doing evictions
okay
they're a little meaner than the one you
talk to
okay you need one that is a little
nastier
that's going to put the fear of God in
said renter because said renter has
decided they're a thief because they got
their little girl feelings hurt little
boy feelings hurt
and said renter is not owning up to a
contract and contract law is still good
even in Maryland
yes I guess my question is just like is
it worth it for like three thousand
dollars yes do not let them steal from
you because here's the thing if you
continue to play from a hand of weakness
they're gonna completely Strip This
House
okay instead if you knock the crap out
of them they're gonna be afraid of you
which is the way this ought to be
very very scary Dave I'm not gonna lie
but you're a lawyer can be I I think you
hire the hit job here
okay you contract out the hit
uh metaphorically my husband
metaphorically speaking Yeah if you're
going to hire a lawyer that does
evictions they have to know how to get
all up in somebody's face
that's part of the process because what
you've got is you've got adults that are
throwing a little hissy fit over here
and we're gonna have to teach them how
the law works
okay and I you really if you do not if
you just ignore this as an act of
weakness or an active I'd avoid
confrontation you're gonna get what you
do you're gonna get they're gonna take
you out
they're going to keep your three
thousand dollars they're probably going
to sue you for the deposit just because
they think they can because these people
are not bright oh don't let them try it
do not let them try it Catherine yeah it
is worth a thousand dollars to give them
a hard time
oh and by the way your lease probably
says you get to add that to their bill
I yeah probably says attorney's fees are
added to the bill yeah most good leases
do in most States
so this is not Vengeance this is I don't
do good with adults having Hissy Fits
okay and just going I'm just gonna walk
on the contract just because I don't
like it well I don't care you little
wuss you get to pay your rent you signed
up big girls and big boy paperwork and
so this is how this works God that makes
me mad I don't like thieves
yeah this is a thief
yeah yeah yeah so I think you do what
you want to do I've been doing rental
property a long long time we're never
mean to people we're never unkind to
people but we do have lawyers do it
sure if they are misbehaving and
stealing stuff and you know they decide
they're going to do drugs and the you
know the dadgum drug enforcements
surrounding my house that I own because
I got a druggie in there we're not going
to do this this is not what we do
so you get to move and we're going to
have somebody help you do that since you
don't have sense to do it sense enough
to do it on your own and do this with
class they signed a contract that allows
you to end it at 90 days from today all
you did was do what you said you were
going to do on the paperwork you've done
nothing wrong you were not unkind to
them you did not violate their rights
you didn't do anything wrong they're
just having a fit
and they hadn't paid their bill
yeah yeah so you really really really do
need lean on them I don't know if you
follow it all the way through or not but
you at least need to represent that
you're going to because that puts them
back on their heels where right now
you're on your heels and you're the one
in the right
so I don't like dealing with lawyers I
don't like dealing with any of this
stuff I don't I don't choose the fight
but these people chose to not pay their
bill
and sometimes we have to have a judge
remind people how things work that's why
we have judges
and I hate it I don't want to do it I
don't ever seek that out right but oh my
gosh
it is a matter of posturing and you're
you're a guy you talk to is a wuss you
don't need to use him yeah she needs to
get more of a pit bull sometimes you
need to hire an attorney that you don't
even like
Brett's with us in Atlanta hey Brett
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave hey Jaden I love your show
listen to your YouTube channel almost
daily so thank you for taking my call
thanks how can we help
yeah so I plan on buying another
investment property with cash within the
next year or two so I've been saving up
so right now I have 83 000 cash
currently sitting in a high yield
savings account at four percent very
cool plan on saving another fifty
thousand dollars over the next few
months good for you with that said Thank
you with that said I want to make sure I
am maximizing the return with the cash
that I have just sitting there I'm used
to investing I'm used to getting a
mortgage and doing investment property
so I'm doing it a little bit different
this time so I have a lot of cash
um what is the best thing to do with it
right now four percent is good but it's
not great I don't want to invest it
because I'm going to use it within the
next year or two so what should I do
four percent is a parking fee you're
parking the money
if you invest the money and don't park
it you make more but you take more risk
as you just said
so if I'm you I'm parking it because
it's the money that you're going to have
for this is not coming from your return
on investment it's coming from you
putting money in the account
correct you're the secret sauce not the
investment
if you do if you make ten percent rather
than four percent over two months
that you know that amounts to like three
percent
difference it's not it's nothing
I mean three percent a hundred thousand
dollars this does not two thousand
dollar you're not within two thousand
dollars of doing your deal here
your deal is a hundred fifty thousand
dollar deal
you follow me
yeah so your return on investment here
is not going to make this happen or keep
this from happening I wouldn't I would
just leave it in the market if I were in
your shoes
got it cool you see what you understand
why I'm doing that
yes I do yeah so Brett people like that
that think like you and I think because
remember math nerds
um we look for something to fix the
investment and sometimes the thing that
fixes the investment is you
you're the one that's doing the
investing you're the one putting the
money in the account not the investment
and so don't try to fix it just pile up
money go do it pile up money go do it
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America lots of live
events going on all around America right
now including the inaugural event at the
new Ramsey Event Center we are just
moving in it was just finished literally
this week and the first public event
will be the smart conference April 14th
and 15th it's going to be a blast all
the Ramsey personalities Rachel Cruz Dr
John deloney Ken Coleman George Campbell
Christine Ellis Jade warshaw all going
to join me as we kick off this event
it's a two-day event or a day and a half
event so here's the deal we're going to
broadcast this show from that stage
for a live studio audience of several
hundred if you want to come to that you
can let us know you'd like to come
whether your company smart conference or
not but if you're coming to Smart
conference come in early be part of that
and then there'll be a few hour break
where you go get some dinner when this
is over and then that evening we're
going to have uh the smart money happy
hour to kick off the uh
kick off the smart conference weekend
Friday evening
followed by some country music icons
there's a couple of them around here in
Nashville if you hadn't heard are going
to come hang out with us so we'll have a
little Nashville experience from the
stage of the Ramsey Event Center
inaugural weekend on Friday night and
then all day Saturday we're going to be
teaching cool and uh it's going to be a
blast and going to have a lot of fun
really looking forward to it it's almost
sold out there's just about like 52
tickets or something like that left
tickets the only ones left for general
admission they're 119 dollars for that
whole thing wow that's great it's a deal
yeah ramseysolutions.com
events and you'll get the inaugural
ticket so you can have the memory of
being at the very first event that ever
occurs and you get to be part of that
experience and we're really we're we're
pretty pumped about it around here I can
just tell you so um a lot a couple of
Building Wealth live events in Anaheim
and in Salt Lake City left this spring
here in April and May check those out at
ramseysolutions.com events money and
marriage event in the fall with Dr John
deloney and Rachel Cruz that is on sale
I think it's about half sold out already
I think it's an October date so check
that out Ken Coleman is coming to four
cities to do his uh career uh get clear
assessment process and sit with small
groups of three five hundred they're not
going to be large events a little three
to five hundred events and gonna be a
lot of q a and so these we're everywhere
you guys we are all over the place uh
career breakthrough that's what that
event that's going to be good yeah and
so you can check these out in all the
different cities all this stuff at
ramseysolutions.com
events all right Jeff's with us in Miami
hi Jeff welcome to the Ramsay show
good afternoon thanks so much for taking
my call I listen to you guys all the
time so I appreciate it well thank you
how can we help
so my question is I just found out from
my current employer that they are
changing the administrator of our 401K
retirement plan and my question was when
I looked through the new investment
options in the upcoming plan most of my
investments my mutual funds don't
transfer over so probably about 80 of my
portfolio so my question is you know
should I should I move this all into
cash before the blackout happens and
then reallocate should I let these just
transfer directly into the new
equivalent funds you know my concern was
some of these I've held for four or five
years bought at lower market prices and
I'm going to be basically forced to sell
them or maybe I'm overthinking this so I
just wondered what you thought okay if
you sell them and there's a profit
there's no tax because it moves just
into another mutual fund so there's no
laws
you don't lose anything you don't lose
anything
that's true I figured when I'd change to
the new funnel I'm buying it all at the
current market price so I'd be some of
the the but you're selling at the
current market price
yeah that's true that's correct so
assuming assuming they're equivalent
funds it's a break even
okay if now if you're moving into a
substandard fund that's a different
issue but it doesn't there's no loss
just due to the transaction
right that's correct I need to probably
look at the equivalent funds in more
more detail but um as you're saying
essentially just let them let them
transfer over let that occur I would try
to I would try to select the funds and
uh it sounds like you may know what
we're going to say where you pick a fund
that has the longest possible track
record I love a a minimum of a five-year
track record I love a 10 or a 20-year
track record on an old-time mutual fund
uh got a little gray hair in it in other
words and uh uh you know that long track
record gives me a lot of comfort and try
I'm obviously picking something that's
beating the S P 500 otherwise I'm
dumping it into an s p
okay yeah it makes sense
I'm sorry if you don't have anything
that beats the s p you dump it in the s
p right
yep no that makes sense one of one the
one fund that actually transfers over is
a you know an S P 500 the next one to
actually have my largest amount so yeah
I mean that's a that's a you know that's
a mid Cap Fund or a standard growth fund
it just happens to follow the index
um and so but you know a standard growth
fund should be performing about the same
way it might not have the exact same
portfolio mix but should be performing
about the same way so uh
how large a company
100 employees okay what do you do there
it's construction management uh building
what do you do there
I'm involved with technology and project
management
so the upper half of the food chain
definitely we're we're uh we're a
general contractor no you are in this
you're not an entry level but you're
also not a senior leader
that's correct okay so but I mean what I
was thinking is you drop in the cfo's
office or the HR director's office who
have made this decision if you don't
like the options and go hey
could we pull some of these other funds
in because there's some good funds they
all didn't put in here
yeah that's a great point and just I was
just what I was trying to figure out is
if you had enough influence to pull that
off
I don't know it sounds probably not it
sounds like the decision's been made
because we only have now the new
administrator can choose the fund
selection your HR Director can direct
the new administrator on to ad funds as
options
I gotcha So Def definitely let them know
what I think yeah and so like if you've
got a XYZ Fund in your current mix that
you love has a long track record has
performed like a beast and it's not in
the new one go in there and go hey look
at this would you add this one this
one's killing it
gotcha they may want it for themselves
you know I mean I I would you know so
that kind of thing but you know uh I
actually had some people come into our
funds our 401K funds and say look that
fund over there is misbehaving they're
doing this this and this and I went oh
crap you're right and we CA we etched it
we axed them we took it out of our
options because they were screwing
around with stuff they shouldn't be
screwing around and trying to Virtue
signal instead of run actually run a
mutual fund and so we dumped them and um
but it was based on a team member's
suggestion but it was a team member that
had influence obviously keyword
influence yeah I mean most of somebody
got hired three weeks ago at an entry
level position it was you know that kind
of thing so it's not not that there's
anything wrong with that but I mean we
listen to anybody but the more weight
you can swing on yeah sorry it's not a
big deal to add for your administrator
to add funds or to take away funds
change the selection mix uh if they want
and you know you know it's you can ask
it doesn't cost anything to ask good
stuff that is a good question so he said
that some of the funds were equivalent
and some of them weren't so for the ones
that are equivalent is that just an
automatic that's just an automatic roll
through well in other words do I have a
I've got a good International
is there a good International over there
if there is it's an equivalent you just
move from International International
I've got a good aggressive growth stock
mutual fund and there's a good
aggressive growth stock mutual fund over
there yeah that's an equivalent then by
good I mean long track record performing
above the index and so I can move it
over there and not have any uh
it's not not a not a big deal yeah it's
just I just got a Chevrolet rather than
a Ford you know but they're both good
trucks right
that kind of a thing and that that's
what we're looking at uh but what
happens is sometimes uh people just pick
sometimes mutual fund people are like
they follow the fads of something
somebody's yakking about in that nerd
World instead of actually looking at
stuff with soul and long track record
and gritty and that kind of stuff and so
I know you just point it out and you go
no don't go over here oh okay you know
they don't really have a they don't die
on that Hill very often
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
scripture of the day proverbs 4 25 and
27 look straight ahead and fix your eyes
on what lies before you mark out a
straight path for your feet stay on the
path stay on the safe path don't get
sidetracked keep your feet from
following evil
Francis Bacon said fortitude and the
power of fixing attention are two marks
of a great mind the ability to focus and
stick with it wow Scott is with us
Scott's in Pensacola Florida hey Scott
how can we help hey
hey I'm I want to know
um about uh
um
bringing my credit score up
financed anything in 15 years at least
or even or on the credit card in 15
years at least I'm 59 my credit score is
a zero as of last week I I looked it up
and I have just a little bit of money I
mean just a couple of thousand dollars
in savings uh I just went recently
unemployed and probably going to be
making about 500 a week of
self-employment life makes about 650 a
week after tax so we have a house that's
uh
we owe about 50 on it it's worth about
222.30 needs some work I can do all the
work uh what Equity because I did
remodels for 25 years and I wanted to
get that credit score up so I can buy
property eventually why you've done so
good for so long without a credit score
why can't you just save up and pay cash
for the property that you want
because at this point you don't want to
borrow
well I mean
um I could do something like owner
finance of a house about to fall down do
all the work and Sweat Equity and not
have to pay for that enormous labor bill
on it
um is the one thing I'm wanted I want to
buy some old houses and
um flip uh flip houses and find owner
finance
um
and with a little money down you know
the thing
um I had an idea of borrowing small
loans against my savings and paying them
off and getting out of zero at least I
think yeah I'll figure out within it
okay let's let's let's stop a second
okay
um you're new to this process around
Ramsey and I appreciate you calling and
uh we we'd love to try to help you get
ahead so what we have learned Scott and
what we teach folks is the most powerful
wealth building tool you can have
is not borrowed money
it is your income and staying out of
debt uh my credit score Scott is zero
I don't have one either
um and so I because I don't borrow money
ever I don't want those people in my
life ever again life is too short
to let Banks speak into my life and own
sections of who I am and so I I'm going
to recommend that you don't do flips
with borrowed money
um the number of people that do flips
with borrowed money and are not bankrupt
within five years is very small the vast
majority of people who do flips with
borrowed money go bankrupt it's a
mythology now can you get into the real
estate business yeah but you're probably
going to have to improve your career and
get your income up you're not making any
money
well my idea was to find people who when
I say a loan that would invest in
um to put up the money invest you don't
need a credit score for that
yeah okay you need a credit score if
you're dealing with some stupid but Bank
and so and the only way to get a credit
score is borrow money so that you can
borrow money why so you can borrow money
why so you can borrow money why it
sounds like we're supporting the banks
when we keep a credit score open because
we are right so I'm going to advise you
to do your deals without going into debt
and if you bring in somebody with you
like a money player like you're talking
about give them a piece of the profits
and you don't have any payments with
them and you don't have a credit score
so let's say you go find a house that is
um
uh worth uh two hundred thousand dollars
but it's all the pieces and you can buy
it for a hundred
okay right your money your money guy
puts up the hundred and puts up some
money for materials and you go do all
the work
and a year later you sell it uh for uh
the 200 and you and the money guy split
the money but in the meantime you don't
have any payments
right okay that's an okay deal I don't
mind that deal
that's what I'm planning on doing
eventually you don't need a credit score
for that what you need is a deal
and a money guy that wants to be in a
deal
okay that's the two things you're
missing it's not I need to go borrow a
bunch of money so later I have the
opportunity to play kissy face with a
stupid Bank
right you don't want to be there man you
work too hard to get away from them
right yeah and in the meantime while
you're doing all that I think you need
to get your income up too you're not
making any money
so let's get your income up you have the
opportunity to make a lot more than
you're making right now if you poke
around out there and there's a different
side hustle different thing to do
there's no reason you can't do all of it
at once uh but don't go being borrowing
that hundred thousand dollars from that
bank and be making payments for two
years while you finish up this rehab
that takes longer than you thought it
was going to take and then it takes
longer to sell it than you thought it
was going to take oh and then you become
motivated because the bank's about to
foreclose now you become the guy who
gives somebody a deal
because you're in debt to the bank this
is how this is how that world works
uh
you know these foreclosures eat each
other sometimes
so that's what I would do sir thank you
for being a new listener I hope we can
continue to serve you
chances in Birmingham hey chance welcome
to the Ramsey Show
good afternoon Dave how are you great
how can we help
um I was calling to get some guidance
from you
um I've been following you for years and
you've helped me tremendously on my
personally thank you for that
um I'm debt free now
[Music]
however I am running into an issue where
housing process and interest rates
um here in my area in my County
um livable houses or at least in the 200
000 range
and I've been working for a while to set
up my down payment
however even
to get a down payment large enough to
get a 15-year mortgage with a payment
that is less than my at least less than
25 percent of my brain home seems to be
impossible
mm-hmm
what are you bringing home
uh my growth is 70 000 I think after
taxes I bring home around 52.
[Music]
okay
which that includes health insurance and
everything today yeah we don't need it
what we're talking about by Telecom pay
is not a health insurance deduction it's
just simply taxes
we gotcha so it did a little different
little different take-home pay than
you're calculating on number one number
two uh I'm looking for some ways to
increase my income if I'm you
so that you can get into a house that
you like
see I've been fighting for the last year
which I intend to say for the next few
years
I'm just afraid that by the time I have
enough saved interest rates and home
prices are just going to continue to
increase well I think what Dave was
saying is is the anecdote for that if
you can get your income up and you
continue to save you're gonna you're
gonna get there eventually but you've
got to do those things combined
in order to make that happen if you
because here's your other option your
other option is you stop saving today
and if you stop saving today then you're
never going to get a house but if you
keep saving and you keep trying to drive
your income up then don't you think
eventually you'll get there
absolutely you will you will it's just
if interest rates go to 14 you're not in
the market anyway right true that
so you're going to wait I'll come back
down at that point so
um you know and I was selling real
estate in the 80s when they were 14.
and when they were 17
then came down to 14 and we thought it
was a deal but um you know six is really
not exactly a hardship compared to
history anyway I mean you have to look
at your options and and none of them is
good if you stop today you're not going
to have enough money saved and if you
bought a house with what you have today
you're going to be house poor and that's
not that's not an option for you so
chance I just want to assure you you're
going to get there yeah you'll get there
you're gonna get there you're going to
get there you're gonna make it don't
abandon don't don't let the fear of
being priced out of the market cause you
to do something stupid be patient get
there buy something you can afford move
up later thank you sir appreciate you
following us that puts us out of the
Ramsey a show in the books Austin Ben
James Zack and Andrew the booth dudes
are pulling it off in the booth I'm Dave
Ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]